hey guys I'm Ryan right a la Nicole here
from the Elana Cole channel she is
really [ __ ] awesome seriously if you
haven't checked out Alana's channel
before check it out and if you have
checked it out check it out again
because seriously her channels really
evolved her videos are like there I just
I genuinely enjoy watching your videos
she is the first person on the channel
that is openly gay that's right people I
am NOT homophobic and I am proving it
Thank You Alana thank you by being next
to me this makes me feel special but now
I wanted to do a special video about
this people were asking about you know
like cuz apparently gay marriage is like
legal in every state now huh
that's pretty [ __ ] crazy it really is
insane like it kind of came out of
nowhere for me I got like text messages
from it from like I'm a friend of mine
was like we can finally get married I've
always had point of views towards this
I've always had issues with it like I
have always found it so anti-american to
not let gay people get married it's
always seem just so [ __ ] up because
it's like they're just people who so who
cares if they're the same sex and and
people who are bothered by it eh you're
[ __ ] stupid at this point because
unless you're in other countries that
really frowns upon it this is YouTube
but in America you are dumb if you are
against gay people now especially in
California it's always been bad not
always but lately it's been like you're
an outsider if you don't like gay people
it used to be such an issue in this
country
separation of state church and state
yeah like it's two different things so
like marriage to the church is gonna be
something different that's okay they're
taking like personal beliefs and it's
pretty get into like state marriages but
that's the exactly opposite of
separation of church and state it's
interesting for me you know like I
thought I take a video because Ilana's
kind of inspired me people have been
asking these certain questions I've
gotten that question before especially
before I was dating brought it goes like
is writing gay and because of some of
the jokes I make I figure you know what
today would be a little bit honest I'm
gonna start sharing
some personal stuff and I hope by some
stuff I share that Ilana will share more
because she shares plenty on her Channel
well actually people also ask me like
the same question that you've been asked
like are you gay gay or bisexual or like
whatever the word is it could be so many
different things yeah I just believe if
you're a person you could be attracted
to another person doesn't matter what
gender you are what race you are unless
of course you're a certain kind of race
that people don't like you know there's
certain races out there that you just
shouldn't date is anyone judging
someone's genitalia yeah unless you got
like a third nut until in reason the
judges yeah oh yeah totally they deserve
to be judged if anything a lot has been
kind of vocal about her on her channel
with coming out recently but with me you
know I'm not I'm not gay and I don't
know like what category you would put
this under but I have done
experimentation there's gonna surprise a
lot of subscribers I have done
experimentation with men in the past
I uh I it was one of those things were
when I try to add a few times and I just
realized this isn't for me I want to
talk to you a little bit about something
that you were saying on your channel
because for me it was a curiosity for a
long time like I was with an
ex-girlfriend and I think it kind of
came from just watching a lot of porn to
me honest like I was watching a lot of
porn you know you just graduate it's
like what's my sexual form like what's
gay porn like I mean you start watching
this stuff then it got me curious as to
like you know I've been watching a lot
of dicks and porn lately maybe I want to
see what this is like a little bit I
tried it out in by the end of it I
realized like yeah it's just not for me
I'm really I'm really drawn to a woman
but but you don't necessarily believe
and I was kind of confused I when he
told ya experimenting yeah yeah I mean
for a lot of people it could be
different but for me I didn't have to
like experiment before deciding that I
liked girls
mmm cuz I just knew and it's kind of
like when you when you grow up just
knowing you
girls like from the gummy I'm assuming
you just like kind of felt like you like
girls like yeah exactly yeah so for me I
kind of just like felt like I liked guys
and girls so for me I didn't have to
experiment but for other people they
kind of have like how you were saying
like you needed to like experience that
to know how you actually felt exactly
yeah for me it was like and time to go
into some little storytelling for you
guys and now and I'm gonna get bombarded
with questions about what happened my
first experience was the most
embarrassing experience of my life
sexually my girlfriend said this
experience was very awkward it was with
a guy who I knew since fourth grade
actually friend know I was like the
disgusting kid in class
Oh like the one with it look at my
volcano boogers in my tissue like that
kind of kid the one that like people
were like he'd be good-looking if he
wasn't so disgusting yeah one of those
kids and then I like caught up with him
like many many years later I was in my I
was just a few years ago I did this
video where I was talking about like I
think I may be bisexual he saw this
video so he's like dude I really want to
blow you you know on this channel yeah
but the channel wasn't really anything
at the time so people forgot about it
was I was hanging out with him and he
like wanted to do something with me but
it was the worst kind of [ __ ] ever
because what he did was he took a
plastic baggie like a sandwich bag and
put it over my penis and there's like a
protective shield yeah because he's like
do you have a condom and I was like
people wear condoms for [ __ ] that's
weird
have you ever had to do that I've never
had does that you might blow someone
with a condom people do that it's
probably gonna get really does it feel
like anything well I don't know you're
the guy it didn't feel like anything
well at least with the plastic sandwich
bag it didn't feel like anything I had a
zit on my penis at the time there I
still had that's it thank you I had to
sit on my penis at the time and he
freaked out thinking it was an STD
second experience was really strange too
that's when I tried out the whole
Craigslist
the casual yeah forever ago right yeah
and so is one of those casual encounter
things this guy hit me up it was like
4:00 in the morning and I was like going
through a lot like the loneliness and
depression at that time so I was like
whatever just act out sexually this guy
came over and literally within a few
minutes like not even like a minute
he was he was just like you want to get
started and you started touching me and
then went for it
same thing happened zit on the penis was
still there so he freaked out and he was
like he freaked out and was like oh my
god do you have herpes so he was like so
paranoid and he he stopped and left
which was sucked but kind of was good
because it was weird yeah you know you
don't really know the person third one
another Craigslist person he was cool
yes he had like a beard and I really
that's what I that's when I started
realizing I don't think this is for me
cuz this is the beard I was like I got a
beard but when I felt his beard I was
like this is uncomfortable with your
beard okay pause yeah so when I kissed a
girl for the first time and like I would
think like when I had long hair I was
like how am I gonna feel like with a
girl's hair right because I not only
kiss guys it's like no hair but like I
liked it okay yeah so it's always been
something yeah I see this what I mean
through my experiences I was like this
ain't for me yeah and you know what's
weird about every guy to that especially
the Craigslist dudes they're always like
do you want to watch porn while we do
stuff straight for they never yeah
they're never like do you want to watch
gay porn they want to watch straight
porn that's really interesting I know
what do you think about those guys who
are like I'm not yeah I just like the
blow guys sometimes why why like why
yeah yeah because it trips me out to you
and guys say that you see a lot of those
Craigslist post like hey I'm not gay I
just want someone to jerk off or jerk
off with but why the last one was
a long story short went inside this
person thought it was a woman the whole
time till I realized it was in this
person's but ii found out that person
had a penis that's the long story short
i was really under the impression I was
I was I was a little intoxicated at the
time I went along with it but I just
couldn't I had the hardest time
finishing I feel like this person should
have told me
you know not not like okay you dress up
as a woman you look like a woman but hey
if you got a penis you gotta say
something you know yeah but no that was
actually a great experience in some way
because that's when I started realizing
one thing like opposite of just you know
like experimenting with guys I realized
how I wasn't a fan of having sexual
experiences without some type of actual
intimacy oh yeah yeah cuz I know a lot
of guys are totally cool with that like
yeah I don't mind just [ __ ] a girl or
something but for me I started realizing
like I feel kind of empty when I do this
stuff I would want something more
intimately involved and I got my
girlfriend after that and it was the
exact thing I wanted I wasn't searching
for something but when it came into my
life it was like the kind of thing where
I'll be like yeah this is sort of what
I've been patiently waiting for it's
emotional part yeah to be like sexually
attracted to someone but also have very
big emotional attraction to someone the
reason I'm bringing that up to you is
because that's the whole point of like
love and all that and you know like
that's one Ilana please I would like to
know like what was your first experience
with a woman like like how did that
actually happen
okay I'll add two different first
experiences and what are you nervous
though that's like three different first
experiences they're three different
first because they're like different
levels of first okay so the first one
was when I was in eighth grade
no person I kissed a girl she didn't
have long hair she
kind of like a boy okay I was young
enough that she said she looked like a
boy he didn't really make a difference
gotcha gotcha yeah so that was just like
that was my first parents kissing a girl
the first time I did anything with a
girl she had long hair and our first
kiss was this like regular whatever and
then first experience getting into it I
haven't really shared this she wouldn't
let me do anything to her
okay and I and she said cuz she didn't
want me to be experimenting it was like
my first it was like after I came out
and stuff and she like thought like I
was experimenting or whatever mm-hmm I
was like by the way guys I'm sweating up
a storm right now it is like
ridiculously hot in here but she did
want me to do anything to her because
she thought I was gonna be like
experimenting and she didn't want that
which I mean I don't know if you're
still doing things to me then whatever
it wasn't anything crazy it's kind of
like hands that's kind of it and then
the last time I don't know if she wants
me to tell everyone yeah she does okay
I'm gonna whisper it to you who it is
you guys both know her the person you
know I think I know you were talking
about already okay yeah one of my
friends is like cuz I was telling her
like I was dating this girl the time and
like we hadn't done anything yet and I
was like I feel like when I get in that
position I'm gonna be like what the hell
do I do and she was like why don't we
just do something I was like let's do
that wow you guys are still friends oh
yeah so you can be friends with someone
who you've hooked up with before did you
guys like go all the way yeah Wow
did not know that and like but then it
goes back to that thing where you were
like oh like you need to like have
sexual experiences with someone that you
like really care about and I didn't
realize that through her cuz like I
wouldn't hook up with her again okay
okay so you never develop feelings for
her how old were you when you first to
start developing feelings for someone
thank you so much I don't know why I'm
sweating so much I mean it's probably
because you're watching this video to
actually I have memories of when I was
in third grade I saw this girl at the
water fountain and she had really long
black hair she knows
she's one of my friends still but she
doesn't know she actually like long
black hair and she's drinking water it's
a water family I was like I was like
thinking like she's so cute look at that
long black hair one of my eyes is also
young and I was thinking like oh I can't
like a girl I see oh I just think her
hair is really nice like I'll just be
friends with her and she's still my
friend well yeah what's the longest
relationship you've had with a woman
that's what about a guy tears two years
okay but you consider good but let's
let's get the definitions out of the way
a little bit
but you consider yourself gay yeah yeah
and it's an umbrella term so for me I
say gay just sounds like I'm not
straight ah that's a good way to put it
yeah that's a good way to put it
okay well thank you Ilana this may be
more comfortable to open up about this
stuff because I feel like I've had to be
secretive about it yeah because honestly
because the you know like insane this is
just setting me up for more comments
like this but the number one used word
for haters on YouTube is [ __ ] so people
will constantly be like some heater will
come across be like what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and what do you mean by that
yeah exactly it's like I'm thinking like
that's such a derogatory word but you're
not even using it in the right context
so should I be offended and or am i
taking offense for other people but
regardless it's still something that
there are subscribers out there there's
a transgender subscriber that we have
and I know this person's had struggles
and I'm sure there's like actual
subscribers who are gay but they don't
admit it I'm kind of just saying it
because like we're in this day and age
now where gay marriage is legal all
across 50 states so I want to be in
support of this because I know there's
gonna be backlash of course and I want
to be in support of this by saying like
hey I've done my part taking a little
bit I'm just so not opposed against it
and I'm hoping that if there's any subs
out there who feel like they're in the
closet or something don't be afraid
anymore
don't be afraid how old are you when you
realize again you just grew up knowing
it well when I was in eighth grade I was
like okay with it and then I stopped
like thinking about it and
I was like completely okay with it this
year but what's really weird is they're
like Veronica is telling me about how
she was in Mexico and there was like a
culture I forgot what are they
the Haitians they're there apparently I
don't know what Asian is Oh from Haiti
you know Haiti is do you yeah in Asian
culture it's pretty frowned upon to
actually be gay she was actually in this
situation where she was in a class where
the topic of homosexuality was brought
up there's a lot of Haitian classmates
and they were just like bagging on gay
people like as if it was like the normal
thing to do it sucks that this isn't a
worldwide thing that's solved but at
least in America it's being taken care
of them you know once they yeah that's
gonna make a big difference I think
anyway guys that's our little spiel gay
talk gay talk yeah that's what we'll
call this video gay talk with Ryan in
the water yeah if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out a lot of
Cole's channel it's a great channel
check it out you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and you have
a vine yeah yeah we have vines to follow
us there because if we get followers she
could get product placements and I could
get more product placement that's right
people
money money having sex and making money
are the two things that make you a great
American so if you're in America you got
to do both have sex make money product
placement is one of the best ways to do
it mark today we're endorsing
homosexuality we're hoping to get paid
from the homosexual community what yeah
that's what I'm hoping for
okay how does it work I don't know knew
I was gay pride work how does be pride
work yeah I always imagined in gay pride
like the actual parade that there's just
a bunch of gay people just having sex
with each other
yeah is that what it's like I just think
it's an orgy Gabe you yeah
like on the float yeah they really I
really did think that have you been
no never been it's just a bunch of naked
people honestly really they're not
having sex
fine I'm walking around with boners oh
yeah
interesting mmm that'd be so soft police
is Darren Cisco I've been to the one in
San Francisco a couple times I don't
know about the LA one but literally
there are naked people walking around
baby we're going reneging we're there a
lot of naked people yeah they'll have
like a little sock or something yeah
whatever I'm not jealous
take care guys I said I'm not jealous